ireland i mentioned that at the top of
the show throughout the pandemic
and across the world politicians have
paraded their top
scientists some may say even hidden
behind them to justify
their covert responses always claiming
to be following the signs but something
very different happened this week
when irish scientific advisors told the
dublin government
they needed to return to a full lockdown
the politicians they said no the tea
shop
the prime minister martin rejected the
recommendation to revert to level five
that's the maximum
alert level in ireland while deputy
prime minister varadka
said that the scientific advice had
been thought through his exact words so
what's going on
i'm joined now by pat he's the political
editor of the
irish times pat did anybody see this
coming it sounds quite dramatic
well it was pretty dramatic last weekend
uh andrew and if we were all taken by
surprise
by the sudden departure from the public
health service
at the public government's public health
experts with their recommendation
on sunday that we should go to more or
less
back to the lockdown we saw
for three months in the spring and early
summer but if we were surprised
by that if the country was surprised the
government was surprised by it as well
only a few days previous to that
the public health experts who meet
routinely and make a report to
government
had told the government that they didn't
see any need to raise the
level of restrictions at that point that
was on thursday
and on sunday they held a special
meeting albeit against the
background of cases which have been
rising
pretty quickly uh over the last two
weeks
or so and uh they made this shock
recommendation that we
we should return to lockdown uh more or
less
uh government rejected that
and not alone did they reject it but
they were highly critical
both privately perhaps you might expect
that but also
publicly of the way that the public
health experts
arrived at their advice and more or less
landed it on the government on sunday
without warning there's an aspect of
of of this that i think is worth just
bringing to your attention for
a moment and that's that the head of the
government's body of public health
experts a guy called dr tony houlihan
who was very much the face of this
strong
medical and scientific advice to lock
down during the first phase
in the spring he's been off on
compassionate family leave
for the last number of months but on
sunday he returned actually a day
earlier than he was supposed to return
he arrived he was due back at his desk
on monday he arrived on sunday
called a meeting and issued the uh the
lockdown
recommendations and this was viewed in
government
by many people and a number of ministers
said it to me
as sort of a power play if you like a
signal that
look dr tony is back he's taking control
we have to go back to lockdown but the
government took um
as you say a very different view has the
government
made clear why it doesn't agree with the
scientific advice it's had
it had two problems i suppose with the
way
with with the actions of the public
health experts on sunday
the first was the manner in which they
did it a very quick meeting
to make the recommendations without
going through the sort of normal
channels that you might expect both
formally
and informally with uh with the
government they simply
landed the uh the recommendation to go
back to lockdown
on the government on sunday night not
entirely
uh without warning there had been some
back channeling but nothing uh to the
extent
that gave the government what they felt
was adequate warning so
governments were annoyed at at the
procedure the process that they followed
but they also took the view
on the substance of the public health
experts advice that while they didn't
dispute the grounds on which they were
making the advice it's very clear to
everybody that numbers have been going
up alarmingly
over the last couple of weeks their view
was that they had to make
a decision which took into other factors
and the minister for finance
for instance was very strong both in
public and in
private that to take the advice of the
public experts and go straight
to a lockdown would cost hundreds of
thousands of jobs
over the coming weeks over the coming
weeks jobs that would not come back
and in his view in the view of most of
his fellow ministers
uh they needed to they needed to see if
a less
strict lockdown over the coming weeks
would
would work so their view was that they
had to take into
uh they had to take into consideration
other elements not just
economic but other social elements as
well
as well as just the public health advice
in making their decision
wouldn't one of the things that
influenced the politicians be
though as you say the number of cases in
ireland is rising
still only about 490 on a daily
basis deaths are two
the seven day moving average of deaths
are two and seven days ago
the seven day moving energy of deaths
were two i mean
maybe a lot of people would think well
if that's the fatality rate
then the government was maybe right not
to follow
not to lock down the economy on the
basis of two
deaths with no sign yet that that death
rate is rising
and this is one of the questions i think
that has to be answered at the moment
you're right about the
the the death rate the figures for today
is there there's only 157 people
in hospital with this illness today
there's only 27 people across the whole
uh the whole of the republic in
intensive care units now of course the
uh worry from public uh public health
doctors
is that you know the the numbers
infected and the numbers that need to be
admitted to hospital and and and and
thereafter into icu
units uh increases very quickly you get
this exponential rise in case and
all of a sudden within a relatively
short period of time the public health
system
is is overwhelmed but there's no sense
of that happening at the moment so
while cases have certainly been
increasing
uh very significantly over the last two
two and a half weeks or so
the admissions to hospital and the
admissions to intensive care units of
hospitals
and the debts have not been rising and
in that sense
so far at least this second wave in
ireland at least i think we see this in
other countries as well
is much less serious by those measures
than the first wave was so the question
i suppose that policy makers and medics
will have to answer
over the coming weeks is whether this
second wave
is permanently and qualitatively
different to the first wave
are whether the hospital admissions the
icu admissions and the debts
will catch up over the coming weeks and
that was one of the things
i think that fed into the government's
decision early on this week
not to move to to another lockdown was
that they felt they had the latitude
over the coming weeks
to wait and see if those indicators
catch up with the number of cases
so pat where does this leave now uh the
scientists and the politicians i mean
you wrote
the relationship between the government
and the scientific advisors
has been fundamentally reset i saw the
irish examiner saying that mr varadkar
the deputy t shock didn't just throw dr
houlihan the chief medical officer under
the bus
he reversed the bus over him again and
again
so what quantum relations like that's a
reference to an interview that mr
veracle gave on television on monday
night in which
as the examiner said it he pretty much
did drive the bus over
uh over tony houlihan now the two men
have since
had a conversation and they say that
they are looking forward to working
together etc etc over uh
over the coming weeks but what has
changed
very clearly between the public health
experts on one side of the government on
the other is that
early on in this pandemic during the
first wave the then government
basically made a virtue of saying we are
not going to make the decisions here
the doctors are going to make the
decisions we will at all times
take the public health doctor's advice
and that's what gave ireland
it's pretty quick pretty draconian
fairly extensive and ultimately quite
successful locked down
in in terms of how it suppressed the
virus uh before the summer
but at this stage in this second wave i
think what the government is saying
given the economic damage that has been
done
and the sort of pressure that the social
fabric both collectively and
individually has been
under in many cases they've taken the
view that
while deaths and icu admissions remain
under control
they have got to take a whole heap of
other factors
into consideration when they're making
their decisions and like it or not that
means that the
public health advice is only the
scientific advice
is only one factor that they consider
rather than the only factor that they
consider so in that respect
the relationship has changed profoundly
i think all right final question on this
before we
move on but i hope you stay with us
because i'm sure people have questions
to ask
because the irish experience is
fascinating to to follow
i assume that the prime minister the t
shock uh has got complete
coalition ireland has always been
governed
but is being governed by a coalition
that he's
he's got the coalition around him
in support of this because if it turned
out to be wrong
and the government actually had to move
to
tougher lockdown steps that would
probably be a political crisis for the
government
yeah i attended the press conference
late in government buildings on monday
night when this uh
after this decision was enhanced and the
health minister
you know when asked this question said
look you know it's not about who's right
and who's wrong here
well you know i think it might actually
turn out to be it's exactly
i was going to say it sounds to me like
it is if the government is approved
over the coming weeks if you do get this
rapid advance
in hospital admissions and icu
admissions and subsequently deaths
and if the government in layman's terms
is seen to have been wrong
then i think you know it will come
under very severe political pressure
at present and we have an opinion poll
which should be published in the irish
times
uh later this evening which shows that
public backing for the government
remains pretty strong and
i i think if it seemed to have got this
wrong
by the progress of the virus over the
coming weeks
then i think just as the politics will
turn on them
i think public opinion will turn on them
and
and clearly that could be very serious
for them
you